we know that josh allen will be in
buffalo
for many many years
here he is
number two on the horse
that is that is a high degree of
difficulty throwing the ball it's one
thing to have a moving target it's
another thing to be on a horse that's
moving while you're also trying to get
to the moving target but alan made that
step that leap last year dramatic
improvement stunning improvement
becoming the guy the bills hoped he
would be nobody knows what a guy is
going to be when they make him a top 10
pick last year allen became that guy
what was the biggest difference you saw
in josh allen from 2019 to 2020 decision
making i think that's the biggest thing
you know always been the talk about
accuracy and it's like no he's always
been able to hit the bullseye it's just
sometimes he tries to hit the bullseye
you know in between four defenders there
with like their hands there and that
that's what we were trying to like wash
out of his football game to a degree so
i think that's the biggest difference in
what we saw you know as far as josh
allen next level stuff also
they went all in on them too with
getting stephon diggs and also opening
up the offense like the things we've
talked about that maybe rogers and
russell wilson haven't had you know they
went to the chips to the middle of the
table mcdermott deserves a lot of credit
defense a coach who finally just went
what go this guy's a stud like let him
go let him fly you know is his decision
making in zen master stuff
of of aaron rodgers quality yet no it's
not but it's not far behind the decision
making special he knows everything
that's going on on the field it's still
really good and then to me where he got
the advantage over rogers
you know is it is again
it's it's what he makes happen when the
normal play is not there
and josh allen you know you could you
could argue no team success as a full
team was predicated more on one player
than josh allen i mean it really wasn't
his skill set is unbelievable you know
his first off beating the blitz doing
anything like that like mike he's he's
next level like here mike he knows he's
hot here but he goes ah wait i can make
this guy miss and get a bigger
completion down the field screw the four
yard completion i'm going to get a 20
yard completion you know here
manipulating the coverage looking to the
left knowing he's got digs to the right
right this is rogers type stuff he's
really really good at it and then boom
like an effortless flat-footed 40-yard
throw like are you kidding me and then
the scrambling you know he is him and
mahomes are the best scramblers in the
nfl the best scramblers and when i say
scrambling i mean behind the line of
scrimmage buying time making things
happen here's another news flash for you
other than lamar jackson and kyler
murray josh allen's
the best running quarterback in football
too he's one of the three best running
quarterbacks in the sport he's a real
threat down in the red zone wherever and
then like this third and 22
like are you kidding me
like
just sit there laser down the middle i
mean it just doesn't matter so many
incredible plays always you know every
game you look at it's phenomenal and to
me that's where i started to give him
the edge over rogers to go wait he takes
what's there within the normal rhythm of
the offense but if nothing's not there
i mean this is what happens oh nothing
was there oh and no big deal 40 yard
laser on the run and then here's the
running aspect i mean it's a guy that's
you know you have to defend it which
allows them to throw that ball to knox
there but you have to worry about that
aspect of his game oh here's this i mean
this is my home stuff fade away drop it
in the perfect spot touchdown
josh allen
you know when you really break it down
and then
again i'm not a stat guy and you look at
the stats
it's it's amazing
people got to stop being hey it's 20 21.
josh allen's a superstar stop being a
hater everybody he's here to stay he's a
phenomenal talent
do you remember when
we first realized yeah that this guy is
an uncanny runner do you remember when
that was well like two years ago
that right or when he first it was three
years ago was that everybody you know he
had september 23
2018 the bills were 17 point underdogs
at minnesota oh you're right
yeah jumping over anthony barr diving
into the end zone we were like holy crap
where what is this
what what is what is this hell that's
about to be unleashed on the nfl no one
knew no no one knew that he could do it
there was so much criticism of his
accuracy and yeah he's got a deep ball
but you know it's
sometimes it connects sometimes it
doesn't all the stuff of the wyoming and
he did
the guy is phenomenal running the
football and the bills
in 2019 was when we kind of spotted
maybe they're being careful about it
they don't want to expose him to injury
they're very selective and when they
design it
but
when he needs to do it when he has to do
it when he chooses to do it it really is
special and it adds an element to the
game it's it's it's a twist on what we
talked about with kyler murray you got
to be concerned about you got to be
aware of it
and the awareness of it the allowance
you have for it
puts more stress on your ability to
cover the receivers because if you
completely blanket the receivers then
he's got an opening for 40 yards to the
end zone definitely he can run that way
and like mahomes this is where i love
him or rogers of you know years past
when he does break the pocket he doesn't
look to run first he wants to break the
pocket and manipulate coverage and throw
a 40 or 50 yard laser but then when he
goes wait you guys aren't gonna bend
you're gonna stay way back there okay
i'll run and that to me is the way you
play football right now at the
quarterback position in 2021 that's why
they're they're almost
you know indefensible unless they're
playing a team that just you know got
their number or they're completely
outmatched that day and you're running
you're right it was 2018. and to add to
that you know he had two games in a row
where he rushed for 100 yards and then
the third game he rushed for 99 yards he
would have been the first quarterback
ever at that time to run for 100 yards
three weeks in a row the first one ever
you know his running is a real threat
you know scrambling's a real threat
you know
even for the gunslinger that he is
yeah here's another stat for you this is
where nobody's had more rushing
touchdowns since 2018 since josh than
josh allen
in the red zone gunslinger right he's
reckless
42 touchdown passes zero interceptions
in his career in the red zone 42 to zero
that's like insane stuff right there so
that's where like we got to get over
some of these narratives and everything
like that uh i mean he went through like
you know unbelievable amount of time
this year of attempts without
interceptions i mean so all these
narratives were busted last year
he is a superstar he could have been the
mvp of football last year you could have
made that case
you know again 40 touchdown pass there's
a 37 touchdown passes he ran for another
nine or eight
everything like that their defense was
just a middle of the road defense they
didn't have a running game i mean josh
allen uh for my money yes is without a
doubt one of the two best quarterbacks
in the game right now
i'm sitting here trying to think of what
it's going to take to get more people to
buy into that i know and i i see two
things very simple very simple
one
when you get your opportunity on a big
regular season stage you got to show up
yes because last year that game against
the chiefs yes didn't show up right you
gotta you gotta seize the moment at
night when everyone's watching and
in the post season
you got to bring it and you got to you
got to take down the big dogs you know
the game against the ravens was not it
will it will be
i know but it wasn't i know it wasn't it
was windy that night but i'm yeah right
right but i'm saying it the planets have
to line up for josh allen so everyone
can see you're right
what you see on film and what pockets of
the country see at 1 pm eastern on a
sunday yeah just like this year first
game of the season against the steelers
it's going to be one o'clock eastern on
a sunday when everything else is going
on he may have an incredible game shred
that defense it's not going to be as
appreciated as it would have been
if it happens
on sunday night monday night they did
take down the steelers late in the year
on sunday night but i'm talking about
when you come up against
chiefs ravens big spot that's those are
the moments when people are buzzing the
next day yeah and they're like wow we we
really have to take this guy seriously
as one of the best quarterbacks in
football no no i hear you i do i think
he needs a few more of those moments to
kind of like you know hammer it home and
staple it down for the rest of you know
yeah the the the not the casual football
viewer or anything like that you're
right but yet still in that though he
doesn't get a credit like he should for
beating pittsburgh in a sunday night
football game or you know the magic he
pulled off against san francisco in a
monday night football game where he made
plays that made kyle shanahan go i want
to draft trey lands because i'm sick of
these pocket quarterbacks i can't stop
this guy right i mean also he's not
given the credit like in a wild card
game against the colts where i'd go
somebody go back and watch the tv
version of that game the bills were
outplayed they had no business winning
the game they only won the game because
of the quarterback they got dominated in
the first half and it was close at
halftime only because of 17. and you're
right we need to see they need to see
more of that but also people got to give
them credit for what's being done here
too and it's 70 completion percentage
you know high four thousands in yards
passing the game is put on his shoulders
and mike there was a the turning point
where i went whoa they trust them it was
week two last year they're playing the
miami dolphins and i i still thought
like you were talking about a minute ago
2019 we're gonna manage them a little
bit here's the game they're down 2017.
he started out hot and you're going all
right now they're gonna go back and to
run the ball play defense sean mcdermott
they come out first and ten down three
whew yeah let's throw a gold route
here's the next throw beasley over the
middle boom on the money second and 24
24 yard gain okay third and goal hey you
know the guy it's magic time i mean this
is it's he's as good as anybody in the
sport not named patrick mahomes and
doing that type of stuff so i went oh
okay
but now it's 24 20 and i'm going well
surely they'll run the clock out here
and this is when i went whoa
they trust josh allen like they're going
all in first off that throw was insanity
in the membranity but then third and
nine up four defense ahead coach
what throw the 50 yard post route like
that that's when i went all right
something happened this off season where
they just they realize josh allen gets
it he knows how to play the game he's
making all the right reads and all that
type of stuff and from that point on i
think we were all amazed what we saw
this year for josh allen here are the
key games to watch
season because surely the bills will get
one of the seven spots in the afc week
five sunday night football at the kansas
city chiefs that is an early opportunity
to put everyone on notice that the bills
are ready to go next level week six
monday night football at the tennessee
titans another opportunity and then
weeks 12 13 14
at the saints on a thursday night at the
patriots on a monday night and then
that late afternoon big spot 4 25 p.m
eastern game
at the tampa bay buccaneers against tom
brady those five games
you show up in those five games you show
up in four of those five games and you
put on the kind of show that we've seen
elsewhere and it's get i think that that
there just will be
a greater appreciation of josh allen and
if the bills win and win and win that's
one way to get in the mvp conversation
but i think he should be back in it this
year
the bills should be as good as they were
last year if not better assuming that
the vaccine issue doesn't create a
schism in the locker room as it already
kind of has yeah but they stay on the
same page they find a way to nudge to
the next level and josh allen finds a
way to to do what he just if he does
what he did last year he doesn't have to
be better than last year just do what
you did last year and show up in those
big games and have big moments and take
down patrick mahomes that's when people
i think are going to appreciate they're
going to they're going to warm to the
idea
that this guy is a top two quarterback
in the nfl yeah i mean i think i think i
hope though i really do you know now
again buffalo needs to be better too
that was they put a lot on josh allen
last year defense is middle of the road
no run game you know so hopefully they
can be better as a football team too
because it's hard to survive with just
going
wait we're just gonna shotgun go all in
on one guy all the time it's not easy
it's not and as good as they are and
they have good weapons on offense they
don't have tyree kill and kelsey in that
group yet they're not there to that
level but last thing i'll say here and
just to go like a little big picture
here to what you're saying and piggyback
off that remember the chiefs and bills
when they were getting ready to play
each other in the afc championship game
this i think will show you just a little
bit of the respect the players have
already and i think coaches around the
nfl for josh allen chris jones made a
comment if you remember leading up to
the game he went
they remind me of us a few years ago
with this quarterback who makes these
unbelievable plays he was saying he
remind they remind me of patrick mahomes
on our team two three years ago where
they were kind of just jumping on the
scene with this amazing quarterback play
so that kind of tells you you know what
the guys that are defending him think of
him where they just go holy crap when
you turn on the film it's just one
phenomenal play after another and i
think he's got the respect of his peers
and the coaches in the nfl right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports